frontman Craig Finn and guitarist Tad
Kubler sat down with Anthony Mason at
Bridge studios in Brooklyn
[Music]
for 20 years now The Hold Steady has
been spinning cinematic stories with a
classic rock score I'm trying to make
these movies for your for your mind that
are set to music you know songwriter and
lead singer Craig Finn and guitarist Ted
Kubler Met in Minneapolis
it's like you turn on a spigot and these
stories stream out
he used to not write anything down that
was his thing yeah he wanted to be he's
like no I don't want to have to write
anything down
[Music]
after their Minneapolis band lifter
puller broke up the whole steady was
born in Brooklyn in 2003 and quickly
built a following
by 2006 their third record boys and
girls in America made Rolling Stones
list of best albums of the year and we
started to create these stories and
eventually started to maybe have the
stories talk to each other a little bit
so songs connected to other songs kind
of create these worlds when you write
music
are you thinking at all about what he
might write
knowing that
there's going to be this kind of
cinematic story you definitely want to
inspire that's that's the goal
[Music]
the music that you guys write and tend
to give to me though there's there's
often space like that you know like like
it's obvious like here's where the words
would go I was rolling my eyes at the
ritual lies okay maybe half of that
happens
where do your stories come from my own
life maybe isn't always is maybe too
mundane to uh match the the bigness of
you know the music that's that's being
given to me is big I need sort of big
things to happen yeah so I do create
um characters that are maybe a little
more desperate than than I am
[Music]
two decades on The Hold Steady remain in
Rolling Stones words one of the most
defendably great New York bands ever
there's a density to your music I mean
both musically and lyrically
uh yeah yeah
there are six of us so uh that's 12
hands right yeah
um well let's say yeah 12 hands in one
mouth
that's the thing about a whole steady
record is that you're not going to
confuse it necessarily with anybody else
that's kind of what you hope for as any
kind of artist whether you're a musician
or
that's what you aim for isn't it yeah
yeah absolutely I think 20 years in I
feel like I'm in more in touch with how
singular we are
[Music]